I think it's also important to note here
that people can't control their emotions
more and more a lot of people's nervous
systems are fried doctors are being told
by medical boards to ask everyone if
they have anxiety I think there also is
a not only a mental health crisis but a
physical health crisis that is leading
to a lot of the insanity that we're
dealing with the consequences of in the
streets in New York City in San
Francisco that that truly is a way
bigger problem very much complex and I
think it all boils down to a lot of food
being poisoned a lot of individuals not
having a good mental health and not
controlling their emotions and then
lashing out and acting crazy which we're
seeing more and more of on on big Tech
social media and whether we're seeing it
deliberately because social media wants
to show it to us specifically or whether
it's really happening I I think it still
deserves to be talked about from a fair
perspective because there are a lot of
people struggling out there that do need
help